what's there to do around here I know  you're upset I'm gonna make it up to you  moms that okay it's just fine it'll be  fine  let's take a look oh you've got bowling  movies by a second escape routes you  said you wanted to try one  oh excuse me well you take it from me  you go up there you're gonna have one  hell of a time oh I'm Michael this is my  daughter Karen Melanie this is Tyler how  about you you here alone  no on the plan and with me escaping  really so what do we do now  we play exactly it is a clue look look  look at the mess I gotta find a  combination  I thought it was escape room rooms can  you it just in relax it's for you hello  God tell your ears listening are we  trapped in here I think you signed out  to some experiment you want nothing to  do with this these places are just gonna  get you to change  tiny joke you guys they walk into a bar  on that system  [Music]  you